[Musique]
c'est un petit village tranquille au
milieu des collines douces ans habitant
une épicerie une boulangerie et des
lotissements tout neuf
tranquille enfin pas pour tout le monde
gellé truche et on s'active
flora et andrey sont à 7 km du puy du
fou et leur gîte ne désemplit pas au
niveau clientèle mollier c'est notre
qu'au motif d'appel
quand le puy du fou est ouvert on a
sonné par presque tout le temps et ont
refusé parce qu'on a plus place chez
paul bégin ses saucissons pâtés et
andouillettes habituellement l'atelier
emploie 25 personnes
l'été c'est aussi le moment fort de
l'année nous fournissons la restauration
du puy du fou
y compris bien sûr l'auberge avec le
restaurant gastronomique
c'est pendant cinq voire six à sept
emplois une retombée également un direct
avec tous les magasins la restauration
dont allant d'août qui viennent
s'approvisionner chez nous ça représente
peut-être 10% de notre chiffre
d'affaires c'est vraiment important il y
a quelques années le camping municipal
belgique
aujourd'hui il affiche complet 90 % de
sa clientèle vient du puy du fou et le
camping envisage de se développer en la
chance d'être situé à quelques minutes à
quelques kilomètres du puy du fou est
depuis une quinzaine d'années voire un
petit peu plus et bien la fréquentation
du camping suit celle de du
développement il lui fit du fou on peut
dire aussi en élargissant un petit peu
que la commune de saint malo du bois qui
comprend 200 habitants a été boostée
aussi par sa proximité là effectivement
grâce au puy du fou
ça maintient à la fois un tissu
économique touristique qui est
nécessaire pour les petites communes
comme
comme la nôtre le point faible et
l'hébergement
conséquence cholet angers et nantes
profite de l'occasion mais au delà des
collines avoisinantes c'est toute la
région qui est concerné la vendée attire
par le littoral mais aujourd'hui on a
des visiteurs qui y viennent
spécifiquement pour le puy du fou et qui
ne vont pas forcément aller sur la côte
d'ailleurs mais qui vont faire d'autres
visites culturelles notamment dans le
maroc doit aller quelques 750
prisonniers 70 permanents 1500 emplois
cette nouvelle est vraie menace pour nos
entreprises
ici on évoque plutôt plus tôt
[Musique]